grande première enfin en appartement
certains objets en cuisine sont vraiment
indispensables un ouvre-boîte ou
évidemment l'ouvre-boîte d'autres un peu
moins
que vous avez un trousseau
parce que dans la tête des jeunes
sûrement que le mot trousseau doit
résonner beaucoup plus avec est recyclé
que le trousseau nos grands mères nos
mères nos grands-mères s'ils prenaient
bien davance préparer son trousseau de
cuisine pouvait parfois durer des années
le truc qui demeure encore aujourd'hui
la planification je passe pour pas les
réaliser beaucoup d'économies en pensant
à autre saut justement pour éviter
d'acheter à la dernière minute geneviève
massé de la tablée des chefs aide les
jeunes à développer leur autonomie en
cuisine pour élaborer le trousseau de
départ elle suggère de considérer
quelques facteurs l'espace dont on
dispose
le budget mais aussi ses compétences
culinaires et sa personnalité
comme je suis moi comme cuisinier comme
cuisinière est-ce que je suis plus de
type four est ce que j'aime faire des
grillades est ce que je fais plus de
type là où de faire des sautés
en 2022 la base du trousseau ressemble à
ceci
sans sa quasi impossible de cuisine est
très excitée parce que j'ai plein de
matériel de cuisine devant moi je suis
comme une adolescente qui sans avoir son
appartement la bc du trousseau dressé
une liste par catégorie préparation
cuisson conservation petit électro et
ustensiles
les couteaux c'est la base c'est ce qui
est plus important donc d'investir dans
des couteaux si une chose d'à parmi tous
les essentiels qu'on va vous présenter
c'est d'avoir des bons couteau n'ayez
pas peur de prendre un couteau de chef
nathalie disposent seulement qu'avec un
petit couteau d'office ça ça va vous
permettre de réaliser certaines choses
en cuisine mais le couteau de chef va
vraiment vous permettre de réaliser
plein d'autres choses la belle des
coupes de légumes d'abel découpe de
viande ou quoi que ce soit
la cuillère de bois c'est symbolique
mais en même temps c'est tellement
essentiel on peut faire ses soldes c'est
vraiment utile dans une cuisine
évidemment la planche à découper c'est
un incontournable ce serait chouette
d'avoir idéalement une planche pour nos
légumes et une planche pour la viande
crue pour éviter la contamination
croisée le plus important c'est le
budget pourtant on a devant soi mais
plus on va pouvoir aller à la chasse aux
aubaines on va pouvoir repérer des bons
d'achat on voit là que pour 3 dollars 25
j'ai plusieurs outils qui m'aurait coûté
plus à l'unité florence les apprennent
beaucoup la 12e vie en cuisine ça permet
de réduire l'empreinte écologique cette
année et c'est d'ailleurs lancé le défi
de ne rien acheter neuf années chez
renaissance et une friperie puis est ce
qu'elles font aller très près c'est
qu'elle pas juste des vêtements il ya
aussi de l'équipe de l'icm en cuisine de
qualité donc on va pouvoir voir
qu'est-ce qu'on peut acheter à petit
prix de seconde main pour ce faire un
truc qui va être durable regardez moi
cette âme un ca de la vie assez solide
on peut tout cuisiner
je suggère un deux types de chadron un
plus petit pour justement réchauffer peu
importe que ce qu'on a besoin de
réchauffer et une plus large chaudron
pour justement la cuisson des pâtes
alimentaires je conseille également inox
qui est vraiment le matériau à
privilégier encore là côté qualité
qu'après un bon fond épais pour avoir
une discussion qui va être vraiment
répartis sur tous les aliments donc plus
votre fonds et tp meilleurs seront
remboursés j'ai un petit et coups de
coeur pur
les poils de fonds peu parce qu'elle
épaules de fonds propres et sa célèbre
de génération en génération
moi je préfère les acheter âgées celles
ci que de les acheter neuf où elle n'est
pas encore polly donc un pur ce facile à
cuisiner quand on sait bien utiliser la
plaque de fonte ça change toute la ville
on a ici un exemple d'un poil on avec un
anti adhésif ça c'est vraiment aussi un
essentiel dans les essentiels parce que
je peux faire tout avec soeur avec un
anti adhésif jeu qui me permettent de
cuire 2002 que me permettre de faire des
sautés la polyvalence des objets et aux
critères d'achat souhaitable voire
primordial pour florence là où la
pratique moi quand je vois ça je pense à
plein d'autres choses que je peux faire
avec par exemple je pourrais me cuisine
neuve et j'ai pas rater qu'en sais tu
jouais portionné congelés mais j'ai
porté ces économique et là je vais
pouvoir et avoir divergé porté pendant
un mois deux mois en sortir au fil de
mes envies la plaque de cuisson ça aussi
je peux faire un million choses vraiment
mes desserts et biscuits mais je peux
aussi faire des plats complets mais
viande avec mes légumes je fais un plein
j'envoie sauf au puy le tour est joué ça
c'est génial aussi bien l'acheter à bon
prix plutôt que d'en acheter une neuve
est encore si pas receler des durable
j'ai pas besoin qu elle soit 100%
l'oeuvre je veux juste mais qui paie
pour être capable de bien la nettoyer à
la maison non pour moi c'est la nuance
est très important
pour ce qui est des petits électro
inutile d'encombrer les comptoirs on
peut s'en tirer avec quelques essentiel
seulement première manier le petit
mélangeur et pratique pour faire des
portions de smoothie ce faire des sauces
des vinaigrettes et s'affrontèrent super
bien donc si je dirais que surtout ça
vient avec deux là c'est vraiment un
essentiel pour aussi acide et noix
hachées des choses qui sont peut-être
lui de se lâcher à la main donc que ça
peut être vraiment une bonne base mieux
le pèle légumes sauce istin essentiel
passoire pyrex spatule rap bol à
mélanger plate conservation la liste du
minimum et quand même longue et en
magasin ce n'est pas le choix qui manque
côté marketing font toujours beaucoup et
faire à nous mettre ce très coloré
intéressant un vibrant mais si vous
l'avez pas sur votre liste c'est que
vous l'utiliserez pop
si nous essentiel rapidement on peut se
dire que tout ce qu'on voit présentement
on s'attire provient bien en mode 300
dollars et si votre budget le permet
d'autres accessoires peuvent venir
bonifier votre trousseau de base une
autre façon de réaliser des économies
c'est aussi de courir les ventes de
garage allez voir qu'est ce que vous
pourriez repéré vous allez trouver
parfois des petites mend a faxé aussi
c'est une autre façon d'aller chercher
peut-être la batterie de grand maman qui
malheureusement ne servir plus ou donc
vraiment des belles des belles
trouvailles à faire de ce côté là aussi
on est dans une ère de
l'hyperconsommation je pense que les
jeunes sont très sensibilisés au fait de
moins consommer des plus éco-responsable
pour donner je pense le goût aux jeunes
le plaisir de cuisiner est
nécessairement ça va passer par des bons
équipements qui vont durer dans le temps
qui vont vous donner vraiment une
satisfaction un plaisir de cuisine